Apple just announced a brand new apple
pencil and this thing is a bit weird it
has some really cool features and
overall not what we were expecting but
in this video I will tell you everything
that you need to know using just a quiet
press release early in the morning and
without a launch of a new iPad Apple
released the apple pencil 3 or maybe
apple pencil 2023 or maybe just apple
pencil
USBC now the interesting thing is that
right out of the get-go you see value
and choice on their headline and looking
at the apple pencil it looks pretty much
the same as the apple pencil 2 that we
have had for years but on the inside
there are quite a few differences now
looking at the tip it looks basically
the same like the apple pencil 2 and we
had rumors of a magnetic replaceable tip
coming out that might have different
options for different people but it
looks the same and then on the back end
we have a little kind of slit or cut and
right away Apple's once again pointing
out that this one is more affordable and
it is bringing new choices now with that
affordability it's cool to see that
there's still saying it has the same
Pixel Perfect accuracy low latency and
tilt sensitivity and it's an Ideal tool
to do a lot of things like taking notes
drawing things like that we have the
same matte finish that I really like
compared to the original Apple pencil's
glossy finish and that flat side so that
it can magnetically attach to most of
the newer iPads this thing also works
well with all iPads that have a USB
type-c for so yes even with the new
lowend iPad 10 that has that redesign it
works great for that but also even with
12.9 in iPad Pros that cost a lot of
money it's also going to work great so
you don't have to spend A1 30 bucks now
the interesting thing is that even
though this does magnetically attach it
will not charge with the magnetic
connection like you get with the apple
pencil too looking at this next image
you can see that USB type-c port right
there and I have to say this looks super
cool that nice shiny uh metallic finish
on the inside and that cap right there
where it says apple pencil well it just
slides out and stays there whereas the
original apple pencil that cap came off
and so many people would lose it and you
just have a lightning Port that can
easily break sticking out right there I
mean we lost our cap and this thing just
stays here in the office so I think this
is a really smart design and with that
USBC connection you can use that to
charge up the apple pencil and you also
use it to pair it and that is great
great I really wish they launched this
thing but when they launched the iPad 10
refresh because with that you had to use
a lightning to USBC cable and then you
needed to use a little adapter which if
you would buy that pencil again it comes
in the box but most people who already
have one you'd have to go out and buy
that adapter separately which is a pain
and then you would lose it um so that
was just a horrible design I don't know
why they didn't come out with this new
one earlier so now any USBC cable is
slid up that cap it stays there you plug
it in and you could charge it up now
unfortunately this thing is not as good
in some ways as the apple pencil 2
because when you do magnetically attach
it even to an iPad Pro it will not pair
to the iPad so it just uses that magnet
to hold it into place but you don't get
any pairing and you don't get any
charging as well so if you have a couple
different iPads you will have to take
out a USBC cable plug the thing in just
to pair up unplug it and then moving to
another iPad you're going to have to do
the same thing instead of just setting
it down on your iPad and switching
between them and it just automatically
pairs now it does have one magnetic
smart function and that is when you do
set it on top it will know that you're
not using it and then it will go into
sleep mode instead of being active now I
don't know how much battery that saves
compared to just setting it down onto
the table and if it's worth constantly
putting it on top but it's nice that at
least it's doing something even though
you don't get charging or pairing now
Apple also put out this little
comparison sheet right here which is
cool but first I want to mention the
price tag of this new apple pencil in
2023 and the cool thing is that instead
of costing
$129 for the apple pencil 2 or $99 for
the original apple pencil and it seems
like they are still going going to be
selling that one because there are still
iPads that have lightning people are
still going to buy those for a while
this one comes in at
$79 so by far the cheapest $20 cheaper
and you get the magnetic connection the
better port and a little bit more
functionality now if we go ahead and
take a look at this chart all three of
the iPads have Pixel Perfect Precision
very low latency and that is a great
thing Apple pencils are awesome at this
comparing to other tablets with good um
styluses they all have tilt sensitivity
so if you're drying or doing something
you're going to have a different um with
that different angle you're going to
have a different effect and as far as
pressure sensitivity this kind of sucks
because Apple saying that with the new
USBC apple pencil you do not get that at
all so the first gen apple pencil that
has been out for I don't know how long 8
years now a very long time um um that
has pressure sensitivity but you do not
get it and that is a weird thing I would
rather have maybe less smart features um
I don't know maybe cutting it down to a
smaller design but have pressure
sensitivity then not have that so
they're still going to try to get people
to buy the apple pencil too especially
if you're more serious about using it
and for drawing now it can magnetically
attach which the original apple pencil
does not and it does not have that
wireless pairing and charging only the
apple pencil 2 gets that now if you have
an iPad Pro it will support hover if you
have um one of the newer ones um that
have that P feature built in so that is
pretty cool it means it does have a
little sensor something built into this
where the original it doesn't but
unfortunately it does not have the
sensor for the double tap to change
tools back and forth like going to an
eraser erasing something going back to
um your marker or your pencil to be able
to draw and lastly you do not get free
engraving on this thing like you do if
you spend another 50 bucks on top of
that so this is very interesting the
apple is bringing out um a cheaper
option while maintaining the other ones
I kind of wish that maybe they would
just replace the original one um instead
of keeping it around or at least giving
this the pressure sensitivity and maybe
keeping it at 99 bucks instead of making
it 79 with the cool newer design and
some of the new things like magnetic
attachment but not giving you pressure
sensitivity but I want to hear your
guys' thoughts and opinions down in the
comments section below go ahead and
click that Circle above to subscribe to
see more great videos check out one of
those videos right over there this is
been Max and I'll see you in the next
[Music]
one